so this really has to be seen to be
believed donald trump and trumpists are
now increasingly furious with fox news i
guess because fox admits that joe biden
won
for example and a fox news also cut away
from a press conference yesterday with
trump's press secretary kaylee mckennany
because she was lying and
neil cavuto said whoa whoa whoa she if
she presents some evidence for these
claims we'll go back to it but these are
really serious allegations
to be making about voter fraud so the
point is trump now and many trumpists
um are furious with fox news and trump
has doubled down
and humiliated himself even more if you
can imagine
by starting to tweet out clips of
newsmax now
if you haven't heard of newsmax good for
you first of all
newsmax is sort of similar to oan in
some
way it's like a low-budget version of
fox news some people say it looks kind
of like a porn parody of fox news
they have massive integrity issues they
emailed their subscriber list during the
pandemic
saying the worst thing you could do is
get a vaccine
because vaccines are one of the biggest
scams among the american people so you
sort of get the idea of where
newsmax is trump now i guess because
he's
furious with fox news regularly is
tweeting out newsmax clips
and you have to see it to believe it
they've set up interviews
where it's not even clear that the
anchor understands the questions
they almost look like infomercials where
the anchor is sort of like uh
tell me all the ways in which this was
stolen from donald trump and then they
just give some mouthpiece
on you know uninterrupted time to just
say
tell lies here's one with an rnc
spoke spokesperson on fraud claims what
can we expect to see in court
we will pursue every legal avenue
because what's going on right now
is a total travesty this is not the
united states of america where we have
free and fair elections with legal votes
cast and that's what who decides
elections not media organizations
now i i'm not going to play long clips
there's a lot more to this but my
suspicion is that
exposure to too much of this drivel
probably is bad for your health i don't
want to do that to the audience so i'm
going to keep the clips pretty short
here's another one with um actually this
is with congressman jody heiss
i'll talk to you about jody heiss in a
moment but
this was around the time trump tweeted
he's going to win georgia
yesterday i don't mean on election day
yesterday trump tweeted he's going to
win georgia
and here is congressman jody heiss
claiming the same thing
because of either reporting or recording
or who even knows what take a look
it's very close and quite frankly i
believe it's on the verge of getting a
lot
closer fulton county just came out just
within the last hour or so
recognizing that they have a significant
issue
on reporting that they did on friday
wxia the nbc television affiliate
is already saying that this is
significantly going to
change the count in favor of president
trump
at the same time gwinnett county has
come out in the last hour or so
indicating that they likewise have some
glitches
now that congressman there jody heiss
he's a disgusting guy
back in uh it was 2014
he claimed that there was a gay plot
to sodomize your children and also in
2014
said his belief is that women need their
husband's permission to enter
politics that's jody heiss who was
interviewed
on newsmax and then signal boosted by
donald trump
and then here is trump flunky richard
grinnell you might remember richard
grinnell
from the rnc he actually spoke at the
rnc
just claiming it's all fraud like it's
just
the entire thing is fraudulent every
single one of these videos i've played
for you so far has been
flagged by twitter as disinformation
about an election take a look
that are now coming back to haunt us
ballots that were mailed
out of state people um saying i haven't
lived
in nevada for years we saw more than 3
000 people
who lived out of state get ballots we've
we've
brought those to the authorities uh
attention
many of those people have broken the
residency requirements
um this is just the tip of the iceberg
so whatever
the outcome of the election is when it's
certified and it is not certified yet
and we still have
tens of thousands of votes yet to be
counted
just absolute complete
and total nonsense and it really
like it's almost getting sad in more
ways than we imagined
and if you are the president and all you
have
left is newsmax clips to
try to make it look like there are
people who agree with you
just pack it up go and play golf the
rest of your term
joe biden has already launched a
coronavirus task force
just announce you're turning over
management of the virus to joe biden the
incoming the elect
administration just go and um i believe
it was trump's former personal attorney
michael cohen who said yesterday in an
interview
he expects that at christmas time trump
will leave and go
to you know his resort in florida or
somewhere
and that he won't even come back to the
white house i think that's possible
trump actually doing things as president
may be over as we know it there's
nothing on his schedule there hasn't
been anything on his schedule
on any day since the election this may
change
but trump really may just be done and he
will just tweet about how he really won
and then quietly disappear around
christmas time we don't yet know
but it's getting really really
embarrassing unless
unless unless and this is very important
unless trump restarts his maga rallies
and there is a report claiming he plans
to do that
and i want to talk about that now